the end of the road begins citizens of
the reject Nation part one
yeah yeah fast X that's what it's called
Fast X gonna give it to you triple X Vin
Diesel it's all tethered together John
good morning how are you I'm so ready
for the last quarter mile or the second
last quarter mile family Coronas let's
do it it doesn't matter if you win by an
inch or a mile
winnings winning yeah that's the quote
families win
G fuel guys get yourself a g fuel promo
code real rejects or something's in
there uh but you get 20 off I don't know
what the promo codes
but it's in the description box it's
gonna kick in in just a couple minutes
you're gonna hear me be really sharp to
talk about all your greatest characters
like Mia oh and Letty and uh and Jacob
anyway let's see what's going on
[Music]
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family he's never looked
more like Groot than now
it's really grown into his bark
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love oh the
price yeah Brian O'Brien
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear Lopez no action
such a beautiful life filled with love
and friends and Roman said family
stole that from me
my future
yes yes
I'm gonna break yours
wow
oh [__]
he looks badass
for you with everything
I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
maybe one of you will but we have to
fight
[Music]
when suffering is old
damn
that's a bar
Holy balls jeez oh my God it's over
Shield
he's trying to tear us apart never Han
oh damn when it used to be obligatory
absolutely
respect race for respect how are they
gonna get a race of all to the story I
race to stop the blood back thanks man
what's happening pink slips having such
a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
oh the shot the shot is rice
why are they racing I don't know
[Music]
settle the score
I'm coming for you son I'm a subtle
stunts thing to depression the most part
well it's the stuff you know could
actually be done for real
never be able to break my family
yes
oh he wins he wins always
oh
that's like a headlight good morning
sunshine you gotta be kidding me
yeah
cool
oh my God girls get it done they do
especially Captain Marvel gets it done
that was uh that was awesome that was
awesome that was a thick boy I'm looking
forward to this one-on-one fight
um
you know what's funny is like while this
trailer gives you like so many action
scenes
um in this in this trailer like which is
traditional Fast and Furious marketing
fashion
and while it has the the gravitas you'd
expect for that Vin Diesel really wants
back in these movies while it has that
I had never been more lost on what the
hell this movies
except that it ties into Fast Five oh
yeah yeah it's like there's a cheap saw
a timeline spiraling you know you had
another shot with the Vault if you take
it into two certification of what was
adding there this is right there right
behind that one wall for years on end we
haven't heard anything about it because
I got the main plot of uh you know I got
the main plot of Jason Momoa Wants
Revenge yeah got it done and he's going
after the family and wants to tear them
apart I understand but the amount of
hopping around locations like whoa I've
never been more lost on what this
movie's about and I love it I'm all for
it because I thought we were way done
past the racing being a significant part
of the movie but I'm like no there's
emotional weight to the racing here
that's right because I thought we were
just doing some obligatory yeah he's for
some reason gonna race and get a shot of
like a bunch of hot women around a car
and I'm like whoa this is a real plot
point in the movie I mean I I was joking
but it really does feel like maybe
they're just like we've we've shot every
single kind of gun at each other we've
had helicopters we've had like aircraft
carriers let's just do a you know like
an actual street race and just settle
this thing because there's still all
over the map here the geography here is
insane yes it looks like a mission
impossible movie more so than the last
one I'm like where's the Letty and
Cipher waking up at yeah and what is
going on and what sci-fi oil transfusion
are they undergoing like are they being
pumped full of Pennzoil or something
like that and there's so many actors in
here there's so many actors in here I I
love it there's like Oscar winners in
there Rita Moreno is Tom's grandma Rita
Moreno you got Brie Larson yeah you got
a Helen mirror Miron you got the Deckard
Shaw's back to face off with Han that is
crazy yeah it took me a second to
realize like wait a wait a minute that's
not right
because it's funny I haven't even hear
much about Jason Statham in the
marketing but he was part of the wasn't
he like the post-credit scene in the
last movie yeah didn't he come back like
punching someone in a bag or something
like that I forget he's wearing exactly
what he was wearing here
his Han in the bag he was really getting
it you know in on him so that when we
come back and they have their square off
then we can really root for Honda take
him down you know I did like how serious
this trailer was too it's a very serious
trailer and and then John Cena's
here uh you can see him yeah for a brief
moment but you know what Jason Momoa
looks he's like perfect for this yeah he
he is a perfect villain addition to also
bring something refreshing to because
usually the bad guys they have come in
are really clean cut and come across
like
um some secret genius
I don't want to say he's coming across
like a dumbass or anything like that
like he comes across like smart and
whatever but he is also very Jason Momoa
it's like an audition for Lobo in a lot
of ways when he's on his motorcycle and
everything and he's still he's he's
still keeping like the the edgy attire
and look that comes with casting Jason
Momoa he's got the style yeah I'm
fascinated to see what this Dante
character is because Jason Momoa is like
I took it you know on the condition that
I would be able to play against type and
be a character who's like more
effeminate and has like you know finer
clothes and things like that and looking
at this I'm like you look like badass
Jason
I mean yeah he looks like Jason Momoa
who's made some money yeah did you say
yeah Jason Momoa who like hangs out in
Italy and buys you know fancy dog yeah
and then you know like Jets over to the
beach to do a street race real quick
this is like a another repeat type of
villain for the Fast and Furious value
you mess with my family now I'm gonna
mess with your family yeah it's a very
classic what would you what else would
you want for the finish I want nothing
more for the finale uh it's it's tying
it into Fast Five I think is cool
because that was the friend that was the
the installment of this that you know
reset uh what what we're looking at
today Fast and Furious could be the
potential of the fast franchise
um I do like that this looks so tangible
though like of all even though I feel
like they did show us maybe a lot and
probably those helicopters are close to
the end of the movie like these stunts
do look more organic than they have in
the past couple of movies where you're
getting full-on CG like completely
impossible looking stuff like here it
looks like they threw down for some
practical stunts that looked pretty
sweet is Brie Larson Cipher's sister
that's what it looks like and I I can't
tell I can't tell who she's actually but
that's who she looks like for sure and
it makes sense because Cipher needs a
family they totally show you the little
bride guy gets taken by MOA dude he's
totally in the passenger seat he's
messed up how could they do that to us
I can't be
spoiled on any story details all right I
need to go in completely blind
well I mean let's not forget people this
could be a one chaotic this could be
like the messiest one of them all
because of what happened with production
on this film yeah switching directors
they switch directors and it cost them a
lot more money like they were about to
shoot they were already there and create
a difference up there I like the
director they they got I think he's kind
of in uh I think it might I like the
director he got they got
um Lewis
letterbox and he's a good director he's
done the transporter film so he's
reunited with Jason's the thumb okay and
he did The Incredible Hulk man he did my
favorite American Jet Li movie Unleashed
so I enjoy the movies he's done and this
looks competent For What fast and
furious is yeah so you still got Justin
Lin on the writing credits there will be
some of that classic shepherding of the
franchise even despite creative
differences true true well guys he
really does look like Groot now he does
an old man he does don't do don't watch
The Legacy trailer side by side how far
we've come from sapling dong to to full
Groot Dom alrighty guys well thank you
for being here please make sure to
um leave a like for the family family
your family too yeah and we will catch
you all on the flippity flip people